[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend immerhin gab es keine
nachtsitzung die ko-runde aus
landesregierungen und bundeskanzleramt
kurz mpk war heute ja deutlich flotter
fertig als das viele wohl erwartet
hatten nach den erfahrungen mit früheren
mp cars das könnte daran gelegen haben
dass diesmal diejenigen denen die
beschlüsse nicht weit genug gingen nicht
im kanzleramt saßen und da der
expertenstab auf den sich oder scholz
und die landesregierung und berufen
selbst nicht konkret formuliert hatte
was genau er mit den geforderten starken
kontakt beschränkungen in den nächsten
tagen meint bot sich genügend
politischer interpretationsspielraum
konkret wurde allerdings das rk ii die
oberste solchen schutz behörde was wohl
nicht jedem gefiel was heute politisch
beschlossen wurde berichtet weniger
olaf scholz hat omikron analysiert und
ist nun gekommen und die konsequenzen
mitzuteilen nur wollen seinen
konsequenzen und analyse nicht so recht
zusammenpassen über die neue gefahr die
neue corona variante sie ist nach
einschätzung der fachleute was die
infektion betrifft noch aggressiver es
ist nach derzeitiger einschätzung
bestenfalls nur eine frage von wenigen
wochen bis diese virusvariante sich auch
bei uns durchsetzen wird
deshalb müssen wir uns auch jetzt darauf
vorbereiten corona macht keine
weihnachtspause eine weihnachtspause
aber will der bundeskanzler dem land
können wie angela merkel im vergangenen
jahr der maßnahmenkatalog bleibt über
weihnachten beim alten 2g im
einzelhandel 3g am arbeitsplatz in
bussen bahnen und fernzügen kontakt
beschränkungen beim treff mit
ungeimpften das heißt treff mit
höchstens zwei personen eines weiteren
haushalts
nach weihnachten werden clubs und
diskotheken geschlossen
grossveranstaltungen ohne publikum
abgehalten das silvesterfeuerwerk wird
verboten und erstmals wird es kontakt
beschränkung für geimpfte und genesene
geben maximal zehn personen ausgenommen
kinder unter 14 jahren man setzt auf
impfbereitschaft und appelle
wir müssen uns schützen und unsere
angehörigen
wenn wir das tun mit all der vernunft
die uns als menschen gegeben ist werden
wir auch gut durch die nächste krone
religion nicht alle glauben dass das
reicht hinter den kulissen hat das
kräftig gerappelt zwischen lka-chef
vieler kanzler scholz und minister
lauterbach das lka hatte kurz vor der
mpk maximale kontakt beschränkung
empfohlen und war damit nicht allein
ich habe heute von bundeskanzler scholz
in dieser richtung führung
bestellen ja wir brauchen alle
instrumente
zurück
und ich finde auch einen lock down kann
man nicht ausschließen es kam anders
deshalb geben baden württemberg und
sachsen ihren unmut zu protokoll sie
halten die maßnahmen für nicht
weitgehend genug und sie fordern
kurzfristig die erneute feststellung der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite durch den bundestag was
passiert wenn es eine so starken krone
ausbruch gibt dass wir in dem bereich
der kritischen infrastruktur
teilweise zusammenbrüche haben das ist
das szenario über das gesprochen wird
gleichzeitig können wir nicht eine ganze
reihe von dingen handeln weil die
bundesgesetzliche regelung dafür nicht
vorhanden dass die dinge passen nicht
zusammen am 17 januar soll die nächste
mpk sein weihnachten sein letztes jahr
kein pandemie treiber gewesen sagt olaf
scholz und hält pro mikro doch für viel
aggressiver analyse konsequenz nicht
deckungsgleich
ja wie gefährlich ist nikon was muss
geschehen darüber wollen wir mit einer
expertin sprechen nach mit der virologe
professor ulrike protzer sie ist
professorin an der technischen
universität münchen und am helmholtz
zentrum münchen und abends frau
professor
% wie viel zeit lässt einen dieses virus
promikon wie ist ihre einschätzung
leider nicht sehr viel zeit wir sehen ja
wie schnell die zahlen hoch gegangen
sind in england in dänemark jetzt auch
in den usa weshalb man muss schon
schnell handeln in england ist die
glaube ich gestiegen der anteil von
omikron innerhalb von einer woche von
von 12 13 prozent auf fast 70 prozent
das ist ja rasend schnell
wirklich rasend schnell und die
verdopplung zeit der infektionszahlen
mit diesem omikron variante die sind
zwischen zwei und drei tagen das ist
schon einfach wirklich sehr sehr schnell
kann man sich denn dann eigentlich noch
glauben sieben tage zuwarten bis zu
etwas strengeren kontakt beschränkungen
oder hätten sie sich als virologin
gewünscht dass da schon schneller mit
angefangen wird wie das war schon in
hamburg auch der fall ist
wir sind hier zum im moment noch auf
einem relativ niedrigen niveau mit dem
nikon infektionszahlen in deutschland
insofern hat man noch ein paar tage zeit
habe ich bin sehr froh dass die
ministerpräsidenten jetzt vor
weihnachten gesagt haben dass man dich
entschieden hat auch möglich direkt nach
weihnachten zu reagieren und mich bis
ins nächste jahr ein zuwarten bis dann
einfach mal schon zu viel schaden sie
mit uns dann auch zu spät wie genau
wissen wir denn wie es in deutschland um
amicom gestellt dass das heißt auch da
wird eigentlich nicht genug getestet und
das wird auch um die gesundheitsämter
kommen nicht mehr hinterher haben wir da
wirklich den überblick oder ist das
kritisch zur zeit
die gesundheitsämter kommt tatsächlich
nicht mehr hinterher das hat aber jetzt
noch gar nicht so viel mit kunden zu tun
sondern das ist noch die auswirkung der
del-tabelle die er jetzt gerade erst mal
am abflauen ist also der welle die durch
die delta variante bedingt es trotzdem
in den testungen sind wir sehr gut da
können wir wirklich ausreichend testen
und wir sind inzwischen auch sehr
konsequent mit den sogenannten mutations
spezifische pcr also dieses virus
einfach mittels pcr reaktion wer schnell
nachweisen und mit sagen welche denn und
auch mit den sequenzierungen stehen wir
in deutschland inzwischen gut da jetzt
noch eine frage werden die virologin und
bürgerinnen die werden sie das denn
weihnachten handhaben verlassen sie sich
auf schnelltests ich gehe mal davon aus
dass sie bewusst sind aber man soll ja
darüber hinaus eigentlich gerade wenn
man sich mit leuten trifft die
vielleicht auch älter oder vorher krank
sind am besten trotzdem noch testen sind
diese tests die man zu hause zum
beispiel anwendet ihrer einschätzung
nach eigentlich sicher genug dafür auch
bionicon
wir sind alle schritt geimpft die dort
hingehen auch die jüngeren jetzt gerade
frisch noch in der zwischenzeit um in
die älteren zu schützen trotzdem testen
wir uns alle nach möglichkeit mit dem
pcr test aber das wird einfach nicht für
alle möglich sein dann mit einem des
paul-ehrlich-instituts
empfohlenen schnelltests dann hat man
glaube ich schon so die höchstmögliche
sicherheit die man im moment bekommen
kann profesor prozent danken für das
gespräch
das interview haben wir über summen
geführten aufgezeichnet und da war die
leitung nicht durchgehend ganz stabil
dass die pandemie wie der name ja schon
sagt ein weltweites phänomen ist hatte
sich für deutschland manches mal auch
schon als durchaus vorteilhaft erwiesen
aus den erfahrungen und daten anderer
länder kann man ja lernen zwar lassen
sich länder nicht so einfach vergleichen
wissenschaftler weisen zum beispiel
darauf hin dass die bevölkerung von
südafrika einen viel höheren
immunisierung grad aufweist als die
deutsche und man deshalb aus dem
krankenhaus zahlen dort nicht den
schluss ziehen kann dass nikon auch bei
uns vergleichsweise milde verläufe
auslösen wird
trotzdem liefert der blick in die welt
natürlich wichtige beobachtungen etwa
wie rasend schnell sich und micon
ausbreitet und wie anderenorts jetzt
damit umgegangen wird darüber bericht
drei unserer auslandskorrespondenten aus
ihren ländern
den heimlichen wunsch vieler engländer
das an den laxen corona regeln zumindest
über weihnachten nicht gerüttelt wird
erfüllte der premierminister am abend
was ich sagen kann ist dass wir weitere
maßnahmen nach weihnachten nicht
ausschließen können wir werden die
datenlage konstant beobachten und alles
tun um die gesundheit aller zu
erste krankenhäuser im omikron
epizentrum london haben die meisten
ihrer geplanten operationen zu
jahresbeginn bereits verschoben
landesweit meldeten die behörden heute
etwas mehr als 90.000 neuinfektionen die
sorge ist groß dass bald nicht nur
personal im gesundheitswesen im großen
stil krankheitsbedingt ausfallen könnte
unsere infrastruktur braucht menschen
die in der lage lang zu arbeiten wenn
sich zu viele anstecken wird das alle
bereiche des systems treffen also wird
gepostet was das zeug hält außerdem
plant der gesundheitsminister offenbar
die quarantänezeit für infizierte auf
sieben tage zu verkürzen doch experten
warnen ohne strengere maßnahmen könnten
bald 3000 krankenhauseinweisungen
täglich das gesundheitssystem heillos
überlastet
lange schlangen am times square in new
york testen lassen denn die
infektionszahlen schnellen in
rekordhöhen omikron ist da und macht
bereits drei viertel der neuinfektionen
in den usa aus es fühlt sich wieder an
wie am anfang der pandemie aber jetzt
haben wir impfstoffe und masken wir
wissen wie wir uns schützen können und
so ist das leben vieler orts fast normal
läden restaurants impfnachweis nicht
nötig mass gereicht tests schwer zu
bekommen und teuer jetzt wird die
regierung millionen kostenfreie selbst
test zur verfügung stellen test und
impfzentren ausbau und krankenhäuser
unterstützen ein lockdown will der
präsident nicht warnungen nur
logisch triebwerks an alle ungeimpften
sie haben eine verpflichtung gegenüber
sich selbst gegenüber ihrer familie und
auch ihrem land lassen sie sich jetzt
impfen
new york bereitet sich vor auf die große
silvesterparty noch ist sie nicht
abgesagt aber experten rechnen bald mit
einer millionen neuinfektionen in den
usa pro tag
auf den pisten in der schweiz ist
ordentlich was los jeder der will kann
hier skifahren einen test oder eine
impfung braucht es nicht obwohl die
sieben tage incidents hoch ist mehr als
doppelt so hoch wie in deutschland die
intensivstation sind im durchschnitt
bereits zu mehr als 80 prozent
ausgelastet die impfquote im land bei 66
prozent vor allem das booster geht nur
schleppend voran omikron wird auch hier
gefürchtet
mit impfen alleine halten wir die
variante nicht in schach es braucht
wesentlich mehr es braucht die bekannten
unangenehmen regeln abstand halten home
office 2 g.de 2g plus und ähnliche
maßnahmen und wir hoffen dass das dann
reicht
im bundesamt für gesundheit geht man
davon aus dass die omikron variante
spätestens im januar nominieren wird
aktuell schätzt man den anteil auf zehn
bis 20 prozent ein auch deshalb gilt
seit montag home office pflicht und 2g
in restaurants museen und kinos
viele hintergründe zur pandemie und
ihrer bekämpfung finden sie wie immer
bei uns auch online auf zdf heute und
mit weiteren aktuellen meldungen zur
krone bringen jetzt die nachrichten
heißt die ständige impfkommission stiko
empfiehlt
auffrischimpfungen wegen der omicron
variante nicht mehr nach sechs monaten
sondern jetzt bereits nach mindestens
drei monaten ältere oder vor erkrankte
personen sollten dabei bevorzugt werden
betonte stiko durch die verkürzung des
imf abstands solle der schutz vor
schweren erkrankungen verbessert und die
übertragung der omicron variante
vermindert werden
die europäische union begrenzt die
gültigkeit des impfpass es der eu ohne
booster gilt der nachweis neun monate
mit auffrischimpfung erst einmal
unbegrenzt der regelung tritt am ersten
februar nächsten jahres in kraft teilte
die eu-kommission mit
in berlin ist rund drei monate nach der
abgeordnetenhauswahl die
spd-landesvorsitzende gefeit zur neuen
regierenden bürgermeisterin gewählt
worden anschließend wurde gefalle
vereidigt damit steht sie nun an der
spitze einer dreier koalition mit grünen
und linken zu ihren vorhaben gehört der
bau von 20.000 neuen wohnungen pro jahr
und eine modernisierung der verwaltung
bundeskanzler scholz hat zum ersten mal
seit seinem amtsantritt in einem
telefonat mit dem russischen präsidenten
putin gesprochen nach angaben der
bundesregierung sprachen sie auch über
die verstärkte russische militärpräsenz
im umfeld der ukraine scholz habe seine
sorge angesichts der lage ausgedrückt
und von der dringenden notwendigkeit
einer deeskalation gesprochen in einer
rede vor russischen militärs hatte
präsident putin deutlich dem westen die
alleinige schuld am konflikt um die
ukraine gegeben seit der annexion der
krim im jahr 2014 hat sich das
verhältnis zwischen russland und dem
westen deutlich verschlechtert putin
wiederholte auch die forderung weder die
ukraine noch andere ehemalige
sowjetrepubliken in das westliche
militärbündnis
aufzunehmen die nato hingegen sei
besorgt über den truppen aufbau von
russland an der grenze zur ukraine so
generalsekretär stoltenberg
das kinderhilfswerk unicef will mit
seinem foto des jahres aufmerksamkeit
für die konsequenzen des klimawandels in
entwicklungsländern schaffen das bild
zeigt die elfjährige balawi aus indien
ein wirbelsturm hatte ihren t shop aufs
offene meer gefegt das gesamte dorf
wurde verwüstet der fotograf pater shaji
zeige mit dem foto den überlebenskampf
von kindern angesichts fortschreitender
umweltzerstörung so unicef
jede ist die korona auflagen nicht wären
viele kirchen an heiligabend wo wieder
pickepackevoll da kommen dann auch
menschen die längst aus der kirche
ausgetreten sind aber auch wenn ihnen
der gottesdienst angefallen hat die
wenigsten treten deshalb wieder ein im
gegenteil die zahl der kirchenmitglieder
sinkt immer weiter auch lassen immer
weniger eltern ihre kinder taufen
tatsächlich wird in den nächsten wochen
der punkt erreicht sein an dem erstmals
weniger als die hälfte der einwohner
deutschlands eine der beiden großen
christlichen kirchen angehören für diese
entwicklung gibt es verschiedene gründe
die in deutschland erhobene griffen
steuer dürfte eine rolle spielen ist
aber wohl keine alleinige erklärung dort
verrichtet
ihr glaube ist lisa kötter wichtig aber
in der katholischen kirche findet sie
keinen platz mehr der machtmissbrauch zu
groß die reformbereitschaft zu klein
deshalb ist kötter vor ein paar monaten
aus der kirche ausgetreten
ich muss sagen dass man gott vertrauen
sehr viel größer geworden ist weil ich
ja weil ich glaube dass gott sich nicht
vereinnahmen lässt von uns und von
religion die kirchen werden lehrer immer
weniger finden den weg dorthin immer
mehr sind der überzeugung glauben das
geht auch um kirche
detlef pollack beobachtet als
religionssoziologe seit jahrzehnten die
zahl der kirchenaustritte steigt stetig
die gründe seien vielfältig oft ist es
so dass man zur kirche nicht mehr so ein
enges verhältnis hat dass man auch das
nicht für so wichtig hält zu sein
eigenes leben und dann kommen diese
missbrauchsfälle hinzu dass die kirche
ein schlechtes öffentliches image hat
und dann gibt es sozusagen den letzten
anstoß um wirklich aus der kirche
auszutreten
bei der vereidigung der neuen
bundesregierung wird sichtbar wieder
einfluss der kirchen schwindet so wahr
mir gott helfe auf diesen zusatz
verzichten sieben der 16
regierungsmitglieder
[Musik]
die gesellschaft zunehmend weltlich die
kirchen zunehmend ratlos sie machen
angebote auf offensive ehrenamtliche
sterbebegleitung viel hilft das nicht
wir leben in zeiten in denen sich sehr
offensichtlich vieles kulturell
verschiebt und verändert zum einen wird
es bedeutsamer werden dass menschen
persönlich einen bezug zu gott bekommen
aber auch leben und bezeugen und auch
dafür gute argumente liefern können und
auf der anderen seite brauchen wir neue
form von vergemeinschaftung
doch gerade die gemeinschaft der
gläubigen leidet im pandemie zeiten seit
fast zwei jahren das virus bedroht auch
das gemeindeleben
da sind wir gerade wirklich an unserem
empfindlichsten punkt getroffen da wird
unsere größte stärke zur schwäche dass
die nähe untereinander jetzt gerade das
gefährlich ist und zugleich sind in
diesem jahr
viele ideen entstanden wie sich das
überbrücken und auf anderem wege leben
lässt dass wir nahe zusammengehören wie
der nähe herstellen und bezug finden zum
alltäglichen leben der menschen es
bleibt die herausforderung für die
kirchen nicht nur in zeiten von corona
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit dem blick in
die wirtschaft und da auf die
verbraucher und die neue gfk
konsumklimastudie demnach schwächen die
korona pandemie und die inflation das
konsumklima in deutschland von bethmann
welche wirtschaftlichen sorgen im
einzelnen haben die verbraucher naja da
geht jetzt erstmal darum werden strom
glas miete lebensmittel alles teurer
wird dann sitzt das geld einfach nicht
mehr so locker dann hält man sich
nachvollziehbarer weise zurück mit
weiteren anschaffungen
da ist eine verunsicherung jenseits der
pandemie entstanden die aber zusätzlich
selbst weiter auf die stimmung drückt in
summe kaufen die menschen weniger weil
die infektionszahlen hoch sind weil die
2g regeln im einzelhandel auch nicht
gerade zum shoppen anregen und weil da
eben noch diese steigende inflation ist
diese anziehenden preise einige ausgaben
werden auch deshalb nicht mehr getätigt
weil so sagen es die konsumforscher die
erwartungen ans einkommen sinken sowas
passiert unter anderem wenn wachsende
teile des lohns einfach von der
inflation weggefressen werden so kurz
vor weihnachten also alles andere als
gute nachrichten die den dax heute
allerdings überraschend kalt ließen das
aktienbarometer gewinn fast 1,4 prozent
oder 208 punkte dazu zu erklären wohl
nur mit dem überaus schwachen start in
diese woche gestern die in einen händler
am abend lapidar mit den worten
kommentierte auf den absturz folgt die
erholung frank bethmann vielen dank
der europäische gerichtshof hat die
rechte von fluggästen gestärkt wenn ihr
flug um mehr als eine stunde vorverlegt
wird eine solche vorverlegung käme einer
flugannullierung gleich so die richter
und könne für die passagiere zu
schwerwiegenden unannehmlichkeiten
führen eine ausnahme gilt wenn die
reisenden mindestens zwei wochen vor
abflug informiert werden oder
alternative verbindungen zu ähnlichen
zeiten angeboten werden
zum schwimmen da hat florian wellbrock
bei den kurzbahn-weltmeisterschaften in
abu dhabi über 1500 meter freistil gold
gewonnen und das in weltrekordzeit
das 25 meter becken haben persischen
golf eine wohlfühloase für florian
wellbrock der olympia
bronzemedaillengewinner mochte die
kurzbahn bisher weniger diesmal aber
demonstriert er von beginn an seine
überlegenheit mit einem zwischenspurt
zur hälfte des rennens wird er seine
schärfsten rivalen los den tunesischen
400 meter olympiasieger haft und der
ukraine romantschuk der in tokio noch
vor ihm gelandet war den sieg krönte er
mit einem weltrekord 14 06 88 fast
anderthalb sekunden unter der alten
bestmarke
und mehr als ein fingerzeig dass
wellbrock bei der nächsten klassischen
langbahn wm im mai auch im becken nach
gold greifen will nach zahl der
medaillen wird er im deutschen team aber
noch von rückenschwimmer christian
diener übertroffen beim sieg des polen
kwg über 200 m sichert er sich bronze
die naz zweite medaille nach silber über
50 meter
die mona lisa leonardo da vincis
meisterwerk und eines der wenigen
gemälde die überhaupt von ihm erhalten
und auch eindeutig ihm zugeschrieben
sind wäre es nicht fantastisch eine
zweite mona dieser zu finden vielleicht
auch eine männliche hauptsache ein
echter leonardo der irgendwo wieder
entdeckt wird und plötzlich ist die welt
um einen alten meister reicher apropos
reich man kann sich ausmalen was so ein
lost leonardo wert wäre wer das für eine
verrückte geschichte hält sie es war
also zumindest der teil mit der rekord
summe die für ein neu aufgetauchtes
gemälde gezahlt wurde ob der
wiederentdeckte leonardo tatsächlich
echt ist das steht hingegen auf einem
ganz anderen blatt dieser erstaunlichen
geschichte widmet sich der
dokumentarfilm oder lost leonardo der
diese woche bei uns in die kinos kommt
matthias amt hat ihn schon gesehen
ist er es nun oder ist er es nicht ein
echter leonardo ein bild spaltet die
kunstwelt
[Musik]
wir kennen nach den gängigen
einschätzungen nur etwa 15 echte
leonardos auf der ganzen welt sich dann
hinzustellen und zu sagen ich habe ein
weiteres bild von ihm entdeckt ist in
unseren kreisen so unglaublich dass man
sich lächerlich macht
es ist nicht einmal ein gutes
2005 kunst jäger ersteigern bei einer
auktion ein obskures jesus bild salvator
mundi der weltenretter laut katalog
gemalt nach leonardo da vinci sie zahlen
11 175 dollar nach meisterhand sieht der
jesus schinken allerdings nicht aus er
ist stark übermalt die renommierte
restauratorinnen der yen modus teenie
säubert das schwerbeschädigte bild immer
mehr deutet für sie darauf hin dass ist
ein verschollener da vinci sie erweckt
den geschundenen heiland zu neuem leben
glaubt es heute fest an seine echtheit
alles ist von leonardo das bild ist
unglaublich kraftvoll es hat etwas
übersinnliches
2011 will die renommierte national
gallery in london den wiederentdeckten
salvator mundi in ihrer leonardo
ausstellung präsentieren eine offizielle
bestätigung seiner echtheit gibt es
nicht aber wen stört das schon die
gallery adelt das jesusbild als einen da
vinci sein aufstieg zum neuen superstar
der preis des bildes steigt über nacht
in schwindelerregende höhen
[Musik]
gerade wenn es um alte meister geht
haben viele superreiche menschen und
auch viele kulturinstitutionen ein
massives interesse an den kunstwerken
sie wollen an sie glauben da zählt am
ende das geld einfach mehr als die
wahrheit
schließlich landet er im auktionshaus
christie's hier vermarkten sie das nach
wie vor umstrittene bild als männliche
mona lisa und engagieren sogar leonardo
dicaprio für den emotionalisierten
werbefilm mit
erfolg
[Musik]
am ende geht der salvator mundi für 400
millionen dollar über den ladentisch
das teuerste kunstwerk der welt wohl
gekauft vom saudischen prinzen mohammed
bin salman als trophäe für seine
geplanten museen in der wüste die
spannende spurensuche fernost leonardo
wirft einen erschreckenden blick auf das
gierige big business mit kulturgütern in
dem es um alles andere geht als um die
kunst
[Musik]
wenn die geschichte rund um sator mundi
fasziniert dem empfehlen wir auch die
doku der letzte da vinci das teuerste
kunstwerk der welt in der 3sat mediathek
dort verfügbar noch bis ende januar das
wars vom heute-journal wir sind morgen
wieder zur gewohnten zeit für sie da auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend fast täglich erreichen uns
berichte über extremwetter zuletzt von
den überschwemmungen in malaysia viele
dieser katastrophen hängen mit la niña
zusammen das klimaphänomen beschäftigte
uns schon im letzten winter war über den
sommer kurz weg und kommt jetzt wieder
dabei weder passat vor südamerika
stärker richtung äquator und treibt das
kalte wasser nach westen noch kälteres
tiefen wasser strömt nach mit weltweiten
auswirkungen
überschwemmungen im osten australiens
gleichzeitig buschbrände im vest
kürzlich der taifun über den philippinen
die wassermassen in westkanada mitte
november
und auch die letzte tornado serie in den
usa wurde durch la niña verstärkt selbst
in europa könnte sich la niña noch
bemerkbar machen la niña begünstigt
nämlich manchmal in mitteleuropa eine
kräftige nordost strömungen das bedeutet
dann viel schnee bei uns etwas schnee
fällt auch in dieser nacht hier an der
ostsee sonst etwas regen im norden
unterwegs aber häufig auch klar und es
bildet sich nebel oder dunst bei
temperaturen von null bis minus zwölf
grad auch morgen über tag kann es etwas
regnen oder schneien hier im äußersten
norden sonst aber setzt sich nach nebel
und dunst häufig die sonne durch bei
temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt und am
donnerstag wird spannend denn von westen
kommt regen heran und wenn der auf den
gefrorenen boden fällt da wird es
spiegelglatt an heiligabend ist es meist
zu mild für schnee am ersten feiertag
ändert sich das guten abend